sexual harassment in the workplace which
you may know from its supporting role on
the hit show Mad Men and look who better
to talk about it than me a man
when will the male perspective on
harassment be heard the public has been
crying out well wait no longer tonight
is the night we've been dealing with
workplace harassment for decades as
demonstrated by this unfortunately
titled training video from 1981 what's
wrong with that huh everything is a
matter of fact when it's unwelcome and
when it occurs at work
okay so first never call it good old sex
you sound like a grandfather explaining
the birds and the bees let's talk about
good old sex tiger because sometimes pop
up likes to stick the old spatula in me
Moore's Easy Bake Oven you get it you
get it the kid gets it but but the fact
is the fact is store brands Ted Danson
is right workplace harassment is
something important to discuss and it's
been in the headlines again this week
with the New Yorkers expose a about CBS
and les Moonves coming hot on the heels
of similar investigations into everyone
from Harvey Weinstein to Charlie Rose to
SpongeBob who five different employees
accused of being unable to keep his
sponge dick in his SquarePants
you're a monster whenever the subject of
workplace harassment comes up you can
bet on one thing men getting very
nervous I think right now men are scared
yeah and you could get to a point where
women are gonna be denied opportunities
to advance in corporate America because
men don't want to be alone with a woman
don't want to be in the same office as a
woman I'm so scared to look at a woman
I'm so scared to compliment a woman I'm
so scared to even a hug woman because I
better have a big enough bank account
for her to turn around and file a
complaint or file a lawsuit against me
huh I'm starting to be concerned that
innocent people are afraid of being hurt
and that's a bad sign and so the
question is what are the rules how do we
find out what they are how do you know
if you're guilty what is going on you
know you know you can tell so much about
a question from the mayor tone with
which it is asked because what are the
rules is not inherently a bad question
to ask if you want to know the answer
are the rules sounds more like an
erections temper tantrum but but but the
point here is it does seem like we're on
the verge of a national reckoning about
sexual harassment major companies like
Ford have had to pay multi-million
dollar settlements and promised to
change their corporate culture a wave of
women are now running for office in
what's being called the year of the
woman and times up was even a theme of
this year's Oscars show now
unfortunately everything I just said
also describes the 1990s when powerful
companies like Ford paid out
multi-million dollar settlements and
promised to change their culture and a
wave of women ran for office in 1992
prompting it to be called the year of
the woman and that theme was the
backdrop of the next year's Oscars
featuring this moment
[Music]
we'll leave
ouch
the only way that could be anymore on
the nose is if after they sang Hillary
will lead the way Donald Trump came on
stage grew up to the backup dancers and
somehow won best picture despite losing
the popular votes conversation in the
90s was largely kick-started by the
experience of this woman and if you are
too young to remember who that is first
enjoy snapchatting your student loan
avocado toast or whatever it is you
people do and secondly daddy's that is
Anita Hill she was compelled to testify
before the Senate Judiciary Committee in
the confirmation hearings of Judge
Clarence Thomas and she informed them
that Wayne she'd works for him years
before she's been repeatedly harassed
she gave a detailed account of
inappropriate behavior from unwanted
advances to Thomas bragging about the
size of his own penis to an infamous
story about a pubic hair in a coke cap
which is the most disgusting thing you
could possibly discover in a coke can
other than Pepsi and and while enough
senators believed Thomas's denials to
confirm him the terrible treatment that
Anita Hill received during the hearings
inspired a nationwide effort to stop
workplace harassment once and for all
now clearly that did not work so tonight
since we seem to be going in circles on
this issue let's try and at least talk
about it if only because no one wants to
see ending workplace harassment as the
unofficial theme of the 2048 Oscars
hosted by a somehow still ageless Paul
Rudd and let's just start with one of
those basic questions that Tucker Carson
wind into his camera what are the rules
it's something that continues to confuse
people despite all those shitty training
video showing examples of a dangerous
office culture have you seen the new
blonde secretary over at shipping
to see the file man listen of you boys
are impressed with her typing and filing
wait until she takes your dictation
[Music]
now I realize this isn't necessarily the
most relevant criticism of that man's
behavior but he just left without
washing his hands that was that was just
zero daylight between the time his
fingers adjust if his colleagues necktie
and the time they adjusted his own penis
but but but the questions what is sexual
harassment actually does have an answer
because while companies may have their
own policies from a legal standpoint
sexual harassment is considered a form
of employment discrimination just like
discrimination on the basis of race or
age it becomes unlawful when it is
severe or pervasive enough that it
creates a hostile environment or when it
includes a quid pro quo meaning
employees have to ensure the harassment
or risk losing their jobs so that is
what constitutes sexual harassment under
the law it's not a single shitty joke or
a botched compliment it's going out of
your way to make someone else's work day
a psychosexual nightmare but of course
behavior doesn't have to be illegal to
be inappropriate anytime that you're
making someone else uncomfortable that's
going to be a problem and some of this
involves judgment and considerations so
is a hug okay well in certain situations
maybe I would argue if it's from behind
never and incidentally is a hug okay
he's Britain's top selling sex ed book
and the answer is simply no the problem
is some people have decided to handle
the complexity of this issue not by
modifying their behavior but by
modifying their staff and I will let
instantly exhausting Easter Island head
to Tony Robbins the author of the book
the worst person you know is currently
reading this I'll let him explain
tonight Tony Robbins taking heat after
these comments
robbing saying some men in Hollywood now
afraid to hire women what are you
talking about Tony you do get them
that's not a story about a problem with
the me to move it right that's a story
about a man who shouldn't be allowed to
have employees at all you you probably
think Jeffrey Dahmer was just the victim
of dangerous men and boys who walked
around all day being too edible now this
thing is unfortunately arguments like
that can slow down any movement towards
finding real solutions and too often
aspersions are cast on anyone coming
forward from they're just doing it to
get rich - they're just doing it for
revenge - why are they coming forward
now and it is strange that we go there
so quickly because that just doesn't
happen with other traumatic events if
your house burnt down you wouldn't
expect a newscaster to immediately start
asking what are you coming forward now
was this insurance fraud wish your house
wearing something flammable and is it
even on fire at all because where is the
line between fire and not fire anymore
it's so hard to tell I'm terrified to be
around houses anymore but with sexual
harassment that is so often where these
conversation immediately goes with
immediate concern less for the victim
and more for the accused there is no due
process right now right now accusation
allegation goodbye everybody gets fired
I wonder if you destroy men or complete
the destruction of men there they're
pretty close to being destroyed I would
say how's it up women exactly it's true
it's absolutely true men are destroyed
it is the end of man women are taking us
down and even worse
they even worship monsters now now that
all the Ghostbusters are women that
means that when we die we'll spend all
of eternity being destroyed by more
women it's not
look look the court of public opinion is
far from an ideal place to deal with
individual claims but it's worth
considering why some who've been
harassed feel the need to speak publicly
publicly because it often has to do with
the fact that we have a piecemeal
inadequate process for addressing the
issue privately the law requires you to
first go through the EEOC before you can
file an employment discrimination
lawsuit and they are notoriously
difficult to win and while state laws
vary if you work for business with less
than 15 employees there is no federal
remedy for workplace sexual harassment
not and let's say you don't want to file
a lawsuit maybe you like many people
don't don't even want your harasser to
be fired you just want the bad behavior
to stop that is where a company's HR
department might come in but people can
be reluctant to go to HR for
understandable reasons HR exists to
protect the company from liability not
necessarily to seek justice on an
employee's behalf and all those guys
that you just saw complaining about due
process should really know this because
they work out Fox News where harassment
allegations are so relevant that their
biggest stars have been dropping like
suspects in an Agatha Christie novel
there were there were multiple
allegations against Bill O'Reilly after
which their parent company responded no
current or former Fox News employee ever
took advantage of the 21st Century Fox
hotline to raise a concern about him and
maybe that is because those women knew
that the huge power disparity between
them and O'Reilly was unlikely to work
in their favor though this is something
that was actually pointed out to our
Riley but perhaps the single worst
person imaginable every allegation in
this area is a conviction they don't
look for the truth but think about those
five women and what they did they came
forward and filed complaints against the
biggest star at the network they worked
out think of how intimidating that must
have been how nerve-racking that must
have been doesn't that tell you how
strongly they felt about the way they
were treated by you wow that is an
admirable confrontational question Matt
Lauer you've really backed him into a
corner pressured him into giving you
what you want
locked the door behind him
metaphorically of course
metaphorically of course but but as we
now know the absence of calls to a
hotline does not mean an absence of
systemic sexual harassment and while
bill o'reilly denied the allegations
against him he reportedly settled one of
them for thirty two million dollars
thirty two million dollars to one person
and that's where the negotiations ended
up and a figure slightly more than the
production budget of lala land o'reilly
allegedly engaged in a lala lands worth
of harassment so if nobody called fox's
HR hotline that might be a problem with
their HR hotline and when you
combine a toxic workplace with a lack of
confidence in systems of accountability
bad things can happen just look at the
US forest service where women have been
coming forward describing a boys club
atmosphere rife with harassment and
retaliation just listen to one employee
explain what she went through in filing
a complaint i wanted justice but i
wasn't like in it for some personal
vendetta i don't want this to happen to
other women and i don't want him to do
it like in the future her complete
detailed several instances of
inappropriate physical contact
once he rubbed her butt another time it
was her inner thigh another time he
grabbed her breasts put his hand between
her legs and groped her two months later
the Forest Service sent her a letter it
said an investigation against
allegations of misconduct was conducted
and we found that there was no
misconduct and so then it just feels
like you're like screaming into a void
like this happened and nobody hears that
or believes that were they hear it and
don't believe it at all that is very
depressing and honestly I can't even say
on that surprise that the Forest Service
is a hotbed of sexual misconduct what
sort of government agency routinely
allows an employee to show up to work
without wearing a shirt and I do not
want to hear the excuse Oh Smokies our
bear of course he doesn't have a shirt
he
personalized hat and belt that
is wise for shirts put one on and look
look the point is it's not about him the
point is she's not alone Abbi bot
a battalion chief with the Forest
Service was sexually assaulted while on
assignment and while she did tell the
police she didn't press charges and her
description of why she felt she couldn't
tell her bosses about the incident is
just heartbreaking
watching somebody that would file a
complaint or make a complaint
immediately became the problem and you
know we have the term that girl or those
girls I don't want to be one of those
girls you know I've I've introduced
myself that way to people I think before
like hey I'm now you don't worry I'm not
one of those girls or one of those girls
being someone who simply says that
behavior is wrong let's do something
about it exactly I was I was trained
that way my whole don't be one of those
girls that is just terrible and the
culture that she's describing is way too
similar to the culture that we thought
we could work to eliminate the last time
we had a big conversation about this
back in 1991 with Anita Hill and re
watching the Senate debate about her now
it is depressing how many of the
techniques used to undermine her are
still around today from concern over
false allegations to blaming the victim
to outright character assassination let
me tell you the law of sexual harassment
is so broad that a person can accuse
another at any time and and and ruin
their reputation just by a unfounded
allegation how could you allow this kind
of reprehensible conduct to go on right
in the headquarters without doing
something about it
I really am getting stuff over the
transom about professor hill I've got
letters hanging out in my pocket I've
got faxes statements from Tulsa Oklahoma
saying watch out for this woman but
nobody's got the guts to say that
because it gets all tangled up in this
sexual harassment crap literally the
only parts of that montage that would
sound at all out of place today are the
words transom and the concept of faxes
again for young people a fax is like if
it it's like if a text message a
telegram a telegram is like you know
what young people never mind go back to
your avocados the tragic fact here is
what we've made progress some progress
regarding workplace harassment since
then we clearly haven't come far enough
so what can we do well I would say the
first step for both management and
employees is awareness of the problem
the next is for companies to develop
workable internal mechanisms to deal
with sexual harassment and for employees
to change those behavior patterns which
might contribute to it change is in the
air though now now that we know this
form of discrimination exists we must
put an end to it and you know what I
think we will and and I'd love to say
I'd believe that but remember that good
old sex video that I showed you earlier
the one from 1981 this is how it ended
the first step for both management and
employees is awareness of the problem
the next is for companies to develop
workable internal mechanisms to deal
with sexual harassment and for employees
to change those behavior patterns which
might contribute to it change is in the
air now that we know this form of
discrimination exists we must put an end
to it and we will yes spoiler alert we
didn't and now I'm saying the same thing
it's like the movie Groundhog Day and
just like that movie there's entirely
too much unacknowledged workplace
harassment happily in plain view
she's your producer bill and it's always
her first day look look the the large
point here is time was supposed to be up
in 1981 and 1991 and now time is
supposed to be up again will this go
around be any different I honestly don't
know but I do know an expert in this
field that may have some suggestions
take a look in 1991 Anita Hill testified
for eight hours in front of the Senate
Judiciary Committee enduring humiliating
questions from a panel of world-class
she's now a professor at
Brandeis University and was kind enough
to meet with me professor Hill thank you
so much for sitting down with me thank
you it's good to be here so it has been
27 years since you've testified in front
of the Senate what has changed in that
time oh there's been a tremendous amount
of change
there's been a change in public attitude
and there's been a change in the amount
of information that we have about sexual
harassment there's certainly more
awareness after the me to improve my
even a few years ago people were
ambivalent about which it the
consequences should be if someone is
behaving incredibly badly and abusing
people they work well I guess the
problem is there that awareness of a
problem doesn't necessarily make
something better I've been aware of
Coldplay for years but that hasn't
seemed to help the issue go away right
people were aware of it but there was no
consensus on what should we do about
that you've suggested you can fix the
women you can fix the guys or you can
change the culture and if we fix the
guys and change the culture we won't
need to fix the women that's right you
know that and so far much of the
approaches we've had is to put all of
the burden on women
one of the questions I got this sort of
6000 to me is you know how do we raise
our daughter to make sure that she
doesn't set herself up to be a victim of
sexual harassment mhm these are the
kinds of things that we're thinking if
we fix her then she won't encounter this
problem in a reality that's she is not
the problem so let's talk about man I'm
a man in the broadest possible sense of
the word let's talk about men's role
regarding trying to fix sexual
harassment do men have a role in that
discussion yes well that's good yes it's
nice to be needed oh well you all need
it we need you to step up I'll realize
at this point in time there are no
innocent bystanders if you are aware of
something you acknowledge it you know
it's wrong but you don't do anything
about it then it's the same as
participating at it is it worth trying
to spot some of the more disingenuous
questions out there because one of the
refrains you hear a lot is where's the
line but it seems like that's often in
search of an answer that will identify
exactly how
to the line they can possibly get so
even eight-second hug is unacceptable I
say great I'm doing a seven and a half
second hug and I'm filling it with as
much creepiness as I can and
unfortunately to some extent the law has
allowed that to happen that you know it
was bad but it wasn't quite bad enough
it was a seven Mississippi yeah and so
and maybe they didn't even realize that
they were getting close to the AIDS
seconds affected say you know now I'm
good with numbers
the law has tolerated at that so part of
the change has to be with the law you
know one of the things that so often
happens is that the law around
discrimination relies on intent did they
intend to harm you well you know if
you're a victim it doesn't matter so
much whether they intended well you did
might not have intended to hit me with
your car but you hit me and that means
that there are repercussions in
consequences regardless of what your
intent was we've seen a lot of men
saying they're absolutely terrified to
be alone with a woman now should they be
scared not if they're not harasses right
[Applause]
should be terrified and you should stop
not do that you know the whole idea of
false claims is something that is
another one of those roadblocks that
people throw out well that that it
really hasn't manifested itself that
doesn't mean that it never happens but
they're so rare and it seems to me that
we don't need to make rules around the
things that rarely happen until we've
finished up making the rules around the
things that are happening regularly so
amend afraid that if they're accused
they're just going to wind up being
dragged in front of some kind of
tribunal with their whole private life
up for a view against people who think
they're lying no matter what they say
and in the process of doing that their
life could be completely turned upside
down can you Anita Hill even imagine
what that might feel
yeah yeah it's actually not imaginative
actually have had my life turned upside
down yeah yeah so let's go back to 1991
you were cool to appear before the
Senate Judiciary Committee and it seems
like you had a set of expectations of
how that would go and that those
expectations were in a very real sense
not met was there a point during that
eight hours that you would find yourself
thinking really this is what today is
gonna be there was a point where they
they said something about well what
procedure would you like to be put in
place I'm a witness I'm on the witness
stand I'm trying to testify and I
thought so they really don't know what
they're doing it's amazing you show
superhuman levels of restraint during
that day but there was still moments
where it feels like you can read not
just frustration but like seething
contempt on your face moments weight
could be projecting this but you were
about to tell Orrin Hatch to go
see I'm not if you had it would have
been entirely justified any of reactions
that I have now in hindsight I felt like
I was entitled to I will also add that
in terms of my display of contempt you
know I've lived through a lot of
challenges and having questions thrown
at me to challenge my competency as a
woman as a woman of color and so much of
what I heard that day was familiar in
tone the questions were different but
the tone was really something that was
all too familiar you were accused at the
time like women are accused now of
coming forward to get rich and famous
how did that work helpful yes well some
people would say that I am infamous
so it certainly worked and in that way
to the extent that I ever wanted to be
famous or rich I had a plan for doing
that that would not have involved the
hurt and harm that was done not only to
myself but certainly to my friends and
family and the people who were behind me
so so let's talk about exes historically
whenever sexual harassment comes to the
fore in culture it seems what we think
about it just long enough to feel like
we've addressed it but not quite long
enough to actually address it what are
the ways that we can tackle the problem
of workplace harassment well one of the
things that we need to do to change the
culture and actually convince people who
you know we're serious about it is to
publicize the policies what and to
inform people this is what happens if
you file a complaint
here are the things that you will do
here are the questions that you will
face here is the process I also think
that there are some management things
that we can do we for example can do
bystander training because I are still
some of them are saying wow I don't know
what to do but I think back now to
myself in the workplace over the years
no I can't honestly say that I
consistently spoke up if I saw creepy
behavior especially when I was much
younger and I felt that I was on the
lower end of the power dynamic and
didn't necessarily feel empowered to
speak out and say that's wrong that's a
pretty poor excuse but but it's probably
how I felt at the time how should I feel
about myself looking back other than
just slightly ashamed slightly ashamed
is a good start that's a very fun way to
put it is that was that thing actual
shame would be at the very least the
destination would aim for cool you know
sometimes shame is helpful sometimes
shaming is not helpful it just makes
people feel guilty and maybe even
resentful
so we you know you have to hear it this
at a moment where people feel empathetic
and not just embarrassing shame ashamed
of themselves if you want to go back to
some of those situations it's pick
yeah what would you do now I think
probably just say that was a pretty
creepy thing to do right that's a really
nice sort of manly thing to do but would
you might you also say to the person who
is getting the brunt of this and say you
know how are you
right how does this feel to you would
you like for me to say something yeah
it's kind of sad that that's not
instinctively I shouldn't sleep well
there is sad a reaction okay how
optimistic can you allow yourself to be
right now in terms of how things are
gonna change I'm certainly more
optimistic than I was 27 years ago
that's a low ball that's a very low
price but even then I was somewhat
optimistic because I have seen people
step up I've heard from women whose
lives have been changed because things
happen differently when they went
forward with their complaint and they
would have expected it to happen years
before so I am I'm hopeful when do you
think this problem will finally be fixed
do you think I'll be wrapped up before
or after the ice caps are gone I'm just
trying to work out whether a safe
workplace and polar bears are mutually
exclusive well the ice caps are melting
pretty fast okay and the change here
seems to be glacially slow right but I
will say that if we do nothing the
change that's not gonna come I need zeal
thanks so much for talking with us thank
you
[Applause]